hey i hope you all had a good weekend
mine wasn't so bad i spent most of it
working on my abs with my personal
trainer
[Music]
i'm the one on the bottom
for a change
[Laughter]
it's too late martha you can't leave
so
we are living in a world run by idiots
where every day something more idiotic
presents itself like a giddy polka dot
wearing [ __ ] blowing a kazoo out of his
butt it's like a parade of swalwells
first arnie duncan he was obama's old
education secretary he's so stupid he
thinks sats stand for sending asinine
tweets
like this one
i'll read it for you have you noticed
how strikingly similar both the mindsets
and actions between the suicide bombers
at kabul's airport and the anti-mask and
anti-vax people here
they both blow themselves up inflict
harm on those around them and are
convinced they are fighting for freedom
that makes no sense have you noticed
arne duncan is a complete jackass
and no arnie we didn't notice strikingly
familiar mindsets between anti-massacres
and terrorists because we unlike you
weren't oxygen deprived at birth
at least a terrorist thinks he's going
to be rewarded with 72 virgins what's
duncan hoping for 72 thumbs up from his
twitter followers
so that was obama's education secretary
great pick there champ no wonder our
education system sucks at this point
somalia is better at least theirs
produces high quality pirates
[Laughter]
it's a sad fact the politicians the
experts the people in charge are dumber
than a cage full of monkeys flinging
poop at each other in the animal kingdom
that's called a scarborough
[Laughter]
look at this graphic courtesy of the
times it's a breakdown of all the
military equipment we handed over to the
taliban 65 000 machine guns 360 000
assault rifles 126 000 pistols
you know that makes receiving 72 virgins
look like a pair of socks
only biden could make christmas come
early for a horde of islamic radicals
but joe you keep spoiling them like that
next year they're going to want nukes
so who made that decision
someone way up there made that decision
how is that person not known hell even
in pro sports if a player blows the
super bowl he or the head coach has to
face the media right after the game
where are the anonymous sources the
media loves to quote with all the inside
scoop behind this scandal
remember trump would hit the bathroom
and cnn would cite 10 nameless sources
claiming he wiped with charmin
but oddly here none of our valiant
reporters feel compelled anymore feels
like some things are just off limits now
of course jake sullivan who looks like
he just left tryouts for a high school
production of pippin
claims the president relied on military
officials advice
not to use the bagram airport and so
another buck gets passed and this is an
administration who said the buck stops
with me but the white house passes the
buck around like it's a dear orgy
disgusting no no no don't no mercy
clapping no mercy clapping this is an
snl
but even the media they're blaming trump
soon they'll be blaming their failures
on old episodes of the apprentice
and there's a report that the taliban
offered biden control of kabul which was
nice of them even savages like the
taliban have to make things easy for
sleepy joe they know any choice harder
than matlock or pudding makes him cranky
rumor has it joe said no to that because
they wouldn't allow him to put a
baskin-robbins in the main terminal
because you know he likes ice cream all
right i'll retire those ice cream jokes
here he is snapping at a reporter who
asks him about afghanistan
i'm not supposed to take any questions
but go ahead
on afghanistan
where am i going
he's got the temperament of someone who
hasn't taken a dump in nine days
hey we get it the job's hard and hard
things make joe angry especially things
that are hard enough to require chewing
meanwhile a marine is fired for asking
military leaders to accept
accountability
he sacrificed a comfortable retirement
to speak his mind we know his name
stuart sheller but we don't know the
names of the people who made all of
these awful decisions is it just joe
that's possible but how can one person
make so many mistakes choosing the wrong
path at every twist and turn he's like
me when i grocery shop drunk the crap i
come home with makes no sense
peanut butter and carrots
and you should see the stuff i eat
and now that it's gotten real bad
they're hiding behind one word consensus
not to be confused with consensual in
case andrew cuomo is watching
but you know what consensus is it's fake
because anyone who doesn't agree with
their decision is dropped from the
consensus so the consensus is always at
100 percent but i guess if you get a hit
at your very first at-bat you could say
you batted a thousand but we know it's
garbage and it's this consensus that
shields the idiots from accountability
even though consensus is made up of 100
idiots the mourinho just got fired chose
to show them what accountability looks
like he did the right thing and in the
biden regime that means he had to pay
the price
[Applause]
like the city she grew up in this
buffalo native is hard-working full of
potential and has never won a super bowl
the story anchor martha mccallow
she is by far my favorite female
libertarian with glasses
host of pine kennedy on fox business
network enemy
and she's on the road a lot meaning she
sleeps in her car fox news contributor
cat tim
and his show is watched by millions and
that's just his kids fox and friends
weekend co-host and host of modern
warriors afghan e-crack extraction on
fox
[Applause]
[Music]
nation so martha
i know
you are a huge fan of royalty
uh we've done a lot of royalty segments
with you are you aware that i am now
king of late night
you wear it very well very well it's not
it doesn't congratulations yes late
night yes it doesn't really fit so i
fired the internet
and i must make a correction you are not
from buffalo
no i know wikipedia thinks i'm from
buffalo it's been going on for many
years that i'm from buffalo so i just
sort of like the fact that wikipedia
doesn't get everything right i do really
like buffalo though it's a really nice
town and it has great little towns
around it but um yeah i'm from new
jersey all right well it's close buffalo
new jersey same thing if you live in
california oh that's true it probably is
anyway let's get to the topic at hand my
crown no
so we had the big news today that they
we got out early what were you what are
your thoughts on this um the military
does a great job
we know that where do we go from here
what what are your thoughts i mean i had
so many thoughts watching your monologue
about accountability yeah
and i thought so much about the people
that we really heard almost nothing from
throughout the course of this when i
watched president biden walk away in
that we heard so little from him during
this we heard so little from general
austin or the chairman of the joint
chiefs mark milley we heard a lot in
fact several times a day from
spokespeople at the white house at the
state department at the pentagon um and
i think today you know the the taking
off of those planes and the ending of
the war in afghanistan is something to
to recognize to to be grateful for i saw
pete earlier tonight just basically
thanking all of these people who have
given so much
so much
all these families i keep i i can't
really stop thinking about these 13
young people and their families and the
mother who is so outraged at the loss of
her son and i just i feel so much for
her but you know what i i think that
this moment of ending like this right it
it takes away a little bit from the
accountability question we've had a lot
of smug prognostication over the course
of all of this oh well it wouldn't ever
happen from a friday to a monday before
the secretary of state went off for his
vacation um and they were wrong about a
lot of things and i just want us to
remember that when we look at the fact
oh they got out 24 hours early well
thank god i'm glad nobody else was
killed on the way out the door but the
the thing is the war might be over
for now
but the war will shift
and sadly other people will die right
because of the decisions that were made
here when you move a piece on the
chessboard and global
in the global environment you leave it
an opening and somebody fills it and
it's going to be russia it's going to be
china it's going to be al-qaeda it's
going to be other terrorist
organizations and
really my heart breaks the last thing
i'll say is this
a friend of mine lost your brother 9 11.
said you know i i want people to
remember those who died on september
11th but i really want them to remember
who killed them
and those people are back in charge now
in afghanistan 20 years later this is a
really tragic sad bookend for those
families yeah
so pete what are your thoughts i think
it's uh we we talked about this on the
five that it this is not about the not
about the bravery of the military it's
about how we ended up in the situation
with the bravest military like
the choices that were made put the
military in an incredible position
impossible position uh and you can
recognize the heroism of the men and
women who are on that airfield for the
last two weeks in the entirely
precarious situation they were in
and thank them and be appreciative for
that at the same time condemn what got
them to that point
and demand accountability for what got
them to that point my overwhelming
feeling when i saw that banner come
across the stream that were out was just
sheer relief frankly for the ones that
were still there considering the way it
had been conducted over the last couple
of weeks the ad hoc manner in which
decisions were made that put us
surrounded by the taliban at the behest
of the taliban and then we had marines
reaching over that barrier trying to
pull in people we promised we wouldn't
leave behind but of course we had and
one of the telling statements was almost
a dismissive one in a couple of the
briefings of there's a couple of hundred
americans there we know that there's a
couple of hundred americans there we
didn't get out everywhere that we didn't
get everyone out uh and those are future
i mean that's pure desperation those are
future hostages in a chess game amongst
islamists yeah uh and now we have a
legitimized a
legitimized terror state
and it the taliban is the word we like
to call them but they're totally
intermingled with the haqqani network
and al qaeda groups we know are
terrorist organizations so this story is
far from written and we don't know who
these 123 thousand refugees are as
someone who's been an absolute advocate
for bringing my allies home interpreters
i knew home guys i fought with home and
we should because of the ad-hoc nature
of the withdrawal of the retreat we were
pulling people into the wire many of
which we didn't know who they people
were running
people just running past when the gate
would open people just run through
and and it's true i mean
it's a testament to what we can pull off
but
you know it also says a lot about
afghanistan everybody wants to get the
hell out right yeah there's so many i
mean there are so many targets and you
know we talk about 250 americans and
that's five times as many as we're in
the um iran hostage crisis yes and you
know look what happened to iran after
that look what happened to our
relationship and i do think and and p
can speak to this but i do think there
are special operators who are still
planning on going in and helping extract
those people because frankly they've
done a better job communicating and
prioritizing and organizing who needs to
get out and to pete's point a lot of
these people were helping uh u.s service
members for two decades and they have
lists of all those people and a friend
of mine who was uh retired special
forces he he texted me today and said no
we're going in there we're still going
in he goes the fat old guys have to do
it now because the government has failed
right god bless fat old guys hey mad
greg i was once one and by the way can i
just say something really quickly you
did such an incredible job at prince
philip's funeral and she's going to do
really it was it was wonderful
a huge fan of the crown and uh i thought
you did such great
service to his memory it was beautiful
when you die she is going to give you
it's the most elaborate
and journalistically sound funeral so
thank you in advance so what you're
saying is i should not outlive martha
mcauliffe no don't because you'll want
me to cover king greg's yes exactly i
don't want i don't want geraldo doing it
god knows what
geraldo do this thing he'll be like i
did the five
with greg gutfeld
for many years here are some pictures of
me
on the beach
he couldn't find any pictures of me with
greg
all right cat take this home what are
your thoughts being married to an uh
a man who spent time in afghanistan yes
and and it's so dry my ad yes
yes he wasn't just hanging out
for spring break
don't hurt her no
um well a lot you know he's been talking
about a lot of people who are more
junior in the military i haven't talked
about this accountability and issues
with the top brass and senior officials
in the military and so you have this guy
who you know gets fired and then resigns
his pension and
gives up millions of dollars essentially
and a lot of people now are wondering so
what does this do does something happen
does this force a change or does this
just quietly go away and then nothing
changes because if you look at how this
happened that would obviously never
happen in any other company where you
need accountability
and that's a lot of the problem with the
military is that the accountability
doesn't exist look at what happened when
somebody stood up and said hey this
isn't cool even though it's been sort of
an open secret among military people for
decades now hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else